So, Joanna, I notice here that besides the
actual allelic composition, I, I see learn more about
sort of lactace persistence. And it says marker
r s and it has some, some number here.
>> That's right.
>> now if I click on that number it
takes me, it, it tells me that it's a snip,
which we all know is in our course an snv
and it gives me this number. What is this number?
>> So that's the snv id.
It's also called an rs id and it's a
a way for everyone to have a shared understanding of
how to name a particular SNV. They're each of, each
SNV is given a name that starts with RS, and
then has a long string of numbers. So, why don't
you click on that. And what we find, if we
click on the, the RSID, is we find that it's
on chromosome two, and it's in or near a gene
called MCM6. and that the versions, the two alleles that
one can have are A and G, which we've discussed previously. And here, again,
we see that Matt's genotype for this SNP is AA.
I think. let's know that you don't get anything more if you click further.
>> So can there be SNP's that have more than two possible options
at that position. Here, I, I, I see that most of the
SNP's we look at have sort of two letters, two possible or reals.
Are there SNP's where there are more. There are cases where there
are three different versions or alleles, but most of them just have two
[INAUDIBLE].
>> If I wanted to find out more information about this particular.
>> Yeah.
>> SNP with this sort of RSID.
>> Yes.
>> Right here, where could I go?
>> There are a couple of databases that have more information And one is
called dbSNP. And dbSNP is really a list of all known SNPs or
SNVs and and it's a place where people share information about SNVs.
the other resource. If you want to learn more about a particular SMV is to go to
SNPedia. So, SNPedia is a wiki where lots of scientists,
put information regarding particular SMVs. you know, what
is known about. how they shape human variation.
>> This means that I could actually type in the allele.
>> Yes.
>> For lactate persistence.
>> Right.
>> Here that we just learned about.
>> Great.
>> And it pulls up this page and it gives me
tons of information about it here. Sort of in a Wikipedia format.
>> Right.